bonjour à tous si je vous demande de
dessiner des branches d'arbres vous avez
sûrement faire quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce que fait mon petit frère
oui quand on a appris à dessiner on
avait déjà remarqué qu' il fallait faire
une branche puis il a divisé en deux
puis que chacune des branches divisé en
branches plus petit et c'est léonard de
vinci lui-même avait établi à son époque
une relation entre le bien m dutronc et
le diamètre des branches qu'il porte et
quand j'ai appris ça ça m'a scié mais
vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé
pourquoi on retrouve toujours plus ou
moins cette forme un groupe de recherche
interdisciplinaire composée de
biomécanicien de physiciens des systèmes
complexes déco physiologiste des arbres
j'adore les mots de plus de trois
syllabes et donc ce groupe s'est
intéressé à la question suivante et si
la forme des arbres étaient juste le
résultat de la lutte contre le vent et
de la compétition pour accéder à la
lumière les chercheurs ont choisi de
tester leurs hypothèses par la
modélisation et ça donne ça ouais faut
reconnaître qu'on est un peu loin du
dessin de mon petit frère
pour créer ces arbres virtuel ce n'est
pas si simple
les chercheurs doivent s'intégrer tout
un tas de connaissances en biologie en
mécanique et en météorologie
ils vont donner à ces arbres des
paramètres qui sont un peu comme leurs
gènes par exemple avoir des feuilles
larges et opaque qui capte bien la
lumière ou des branches solide ou être
capable de faire pousser de nouvelles
branches rapidement et puis le modèle
inclut de règles qui sont issus de deux
découverte récente d'une part la
localisation des nouvelles branches qui
bourgeonnent dépend de la lumière reçue
et d'autre part le diamètre des branches
est contrôlé par les effets du vent et
ça s'appelle la digue morphogénèse bams
icilaba parfait sauf que tout ça ne
suffit pas à expliquer la croissance
d'un arbre dans une forêt il manque un
élément clé l'évolution oui les
paramètres ou les gènes des arbres dont
je vous parlais ont une certaine
variabilité à l'échelle d'une forêt un
arbre va avoir des branches plus solides
l'autre va être plus sensibles à la
lumière et certaines mutations peuvent
apparaître au cours de l'évolution
l'évolution est ensuite simulé sur une
île virtuelle baigné de soleil et de
vent pourquoi une île non pas parce que
les chercheurs révèlent partir en
vacances côté mais parce qu'on peut
supposer qu'elle est isolée et qu'elle
ne reçoit pas de graines de l'extérieur
voici une représentation des différentes
espèces sur une île forêt de vingt mille
arbres
chacun des points représente un arbre et
la taille du point représente l'étendue
de son feuillage les couleurs
correspondent à des variétés d'arbres
différentes donc avec des paramètres
gènes différents
ce qu'on constate d'abord c'est une
sélection naturelle enfin virtuel du
coût des arbres ayant les propriétés les
plus favorables à la survie
donc bon jeu robuste croissance rapide
et à la fin on a plus que la variété
d'arbres représenté en verre à et au cas
où vous ne l'auriez pas remarqué vous
venez de voir l'évolution d'une forêt de
vingt mille arbres pendant dix mille ans
rien que ça on peut aussi rentrer dans
cette forêt virtuel et observer la
structure des arbres les chercheurs ont
mis en évidence que la compétition pour
la lumière va contrôler la division
branches et donner une forme fractales
aux arbres et ils ont montré qu'il
existe un lien entre opacité du
feuillage et dimensions fractales de
l'arbre de son côté la réponse au vent
pour rappel tig morphogénèse sicile
l'âme influencent l'évolution du
diamètre des branches et en bonus les
chercheurs ont même montré que l'on
retrouve la loi de léonard de vinci sur
la taille des branches dans un arbre la
somme des sections des branches porté
par un trou est égale à la section de ce
tronc en tout cas cette étude a montré
que le couple lumière vent à lui seul
permet de faire émerger la forme bien
connue des arbres d'aujourd'hui voilà
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce sujet
parce que moi en tout cas ça m'a bien
branché et surtout n'oublie pas ta
bonnet